color purple was just a labor of love
from all of us it was a challenge for
each of us Steven it was his first
dramatic film it was Whoopi's first film
ever
Oprah's first film ever my first a film
I'd done a lot of TV and prior to that
I've been had done a lot of
blaxploitation films but never such a
film of that caliber and we all wanted
to please Alice Walker
it's a writer of her Pulitzer
prize-winning book - the color purple
and we all say that it was probably
divine order in some kind of ways
because Oprah spelled backwards is Harpo
and Harpo was the name of the husband in
the film so later she did name you'll
see her production company is called
Harpo my name is Margaret Avery the
character's name is sug Avery in the art
department the locals of North Carolina
that's where we filmed said you're not
going to grow those flowers it's out of
season forget it well our opening scene
when you see it you'll see all these
beautiful color purple flowers that grew
out of season the the birth seemed that
you'll see that was shot at Universal
Studios and we stayed there because
aiming Stevens first wife was pregnant
and was about to give birth so we didn't
want it even didn't want to go to North
Carolina during that time so the very
day that we shot the birth scene Amy
went into labor and delivered Stevens
son how could that be the makeup you'll
see in the film it's a it's a it's a
time span of about 40 years and so as we
aged with characters the makeup got
thicker and in North Carolina
I think all the East Coast maybe parts
of the south you've got these gnats and
so they come and they stick to your
makeup and they get upset and they're
trying to get out and you want to go but
if the cameras really rolling you try to
save the shot and you just go ahead and
do the scene and I'm sure Oprah had some
some moments like that and I just she
was just such a pro you you know you
can't tell that's her first film at that
time when the when color purple came out
there was no other black film that had
been released for probably six to eight
years if any of you saw the wonderful
film sounder do you remember that one
it's a little independent film starring
Cicely Tyson and Paul Winchell and it
was about a sharecropper family and
their struggles and it had all these
beautiful strong positive images so here
comes color purple with its statements
and so I think that when a culture such
as ours we don't don't have a lot of
films when one finally comes along
people kind of want it to represent
themselves because remember we didn't
have the John Singleton's and the Tyler
Perry's and all of that right then so
hopefully in the future if we have black
films we'll have a lot of them so that
when actors I'm hoping when I do a film
I don't have to represent my people
that's really a burden for the film
writer and for actors the film has
become not just a black film but a
universal film and my hope is is that
one day when we see a film that it will
truly represent what our world today is
and has become and that's not one of
color but of diversification because
America now is like the melting pot
that's our culture now of all different
kinds of hues so I hope that when you
see and view the film tonight that you
will sense the love and the the care
that everyone involved with the film
throughout their into it it was just as
I said earlier a labor of love
we just love this film and when you
leave here tonight I hope that you will
take a part of that love with you and
walk with a lighter heart
you